[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit jana
pareigis herzlich willkommen über alles
wichtige vom sport hält 10 norbert
lehmann auf dem laufenden
und wir schauen heute unter anderem auf
einen bisher weltweit einmaligen prozess
dieses urteil setzt ein zeichen ein
syrischer geheimdienstler wird in
deutschland verurteilt wegen mordes und
folter in einem gefängnis
wer bekommt noch einen pcr-test wegen
omikron sind die kapazitäten am limit
jetzt wird über eine priorisierung
nachgedacht
ein schiff ein felsen und das versagen
eines kapitäns vor zehn jahren
havarierte die costa concordia
32 menschen starben
in koblenz hat ein gericht ein
historisches urteil gesprochen das
weltweit erste in dem es um folter im
syrischen bürgerkrieg geht es lautet
lebenslänglich für an was lahm er war
vor zehn jahren vernehmung chef in einem
gefängnis in damaskus und verantwortlich
für die folter von tausenden menschen
dann desertierte er floh 20 14 nach
deutschland wurde von ebenfalls
geflüchteten opfern hier erkannt 2020
begann der prozess wegen besonderer
schwere der verbrechen weil er in
deutschland möglich julia schröter
108 tage dauerte der prozess gegen anwar
aslan 80 zeugen sagten aus das
oberlandesgericht koblenz hat sich zeit
genommen nun das urteil der ehemalige
vernehmung chef eines geheimdienst
gefängnisses bekommt eine lebenslange
haftstrafe unter anderem wegen
verbrechen gegen die menschlichkeit
27 fachen mordes und vier tausendfacher
folter
wir sind mit dem urteil des
oberlandesgerichts koblenz sehr
zufrieden denn es bestätigt dass das
syrische regime seit frühjahr 2011
menschlichkeit verbrechen gegen die
eigene bevölkerung begangen hat der
angeklagte war ein teil des systems
rückblick 2011 und zwölf demonstrierten
während des arabischen frühlings auch in
syrien zehntausende für demokratie
regime schlug die proteste brutal nieder
und folterte systematisch so das gericht
an was lahm war dafür mitverantwortlich
später flüchteten er und ein weiterer
syrer der bereits wegen beihilfe
verurteilt wurde nach deutschland
ehemalige opfer erkannten die beiden
einige waren nebenkläger am prozess sie
sind nach dem urteil erleichtert
für mich ist auch eine klare signal für
die vor allem für die syrische
bevölkerung dass die verbrechen durch
der syrische regime
sind sie werden nicht strafbar bleiben
was wir uns erhoffen natürlich ist ein
ideal das wir nie erreichen werden
nämlich gerechtigkeit gerechtigkeit für
verbrechen dieser art kann es einfach
nicht geben wir können nur schritte
dahin unternehmen und ich glaube heute
ist ein ganz großer und ganz wichtiger
schritt gewesen
menschenrechtlerinnen das urteil einen
meilenstein und ein wichtiges signal an
täter und opfer weltweit die
verteidigung will in revision gehen
und diesen historischen urteilsspruch
hat im gerichtssaal unsere leiterin der
rechts redaktion verfolg guten abend
sache attacke
welche wirkung hat dieses urteil
dieses urteil wird weltweit beachtet
werden weil es auch eine kampfansage ist
an alle kriegsverbrecher die mode ist
ganz klar egal wo auf der welt sie
untertauchen überall können
kriegsverbrecher jederzeit verurteilt
werden und genau das gibt angehörigen
und überlebenden solcher verbrechen
hoffnung ich habe sie heute im
gerichtssaal gesprochen und sie haben
auch mit tränen in den augen gesagt dass
sie dankbar sind dankbar dass sie hier
gehört wurden dankbar dass das gericht
an 108 behandlungstagen in zwei jahren
ihnen die möglichkeit gegeben haben dass
diese verbrechen aufgeklärt wurden eine
klare ansage an kriegsverbrecher ist
denn mit weiteren verfahren zu rechnen
ja schon kommende woche in frankfurt
wird der nächste scherge des assad
regimes vor gericht stehen und es gibt
ähnliche ermittlungen in österreich in
schweden in norwegen die zu weiteren
prozessen führen können und grundlage
des ganzen ist das sogenannte
weltrechtsprinzip das heißt dass wir als
menschheit uns darauf verständigt haben
das taten die besonders krass besonders
gravierend besonders beachtenswert sind
nie solche kriegsverbrechen dass die
verfolgt und bestraft werden denn egal
wo auf der welt sie passieren egal wem
sie passieren und dieses verfahren ist
das erste das auf diesem prinzip
begonnen hat und jetzt zu ende gegangen
ist und deutschland zeit damit
mustergültig wie man mit
kriegsverbrechern umgehen kann es zeigt
aber auch was hier in deutschland über
jahrzehnte mit den eigenen
kriegsverbrechern aus der ns zeit
versäumt wurde vielen dank für diese
anordnung sei attacke
jetzt zu corona
bundesgesundheitsminister lauterbach hat
wegen der stark steigenden
infektionszahlen eindringlich dazu
aufgerufen sich impfen zu lassen und
sich erneut für eine allgemeine
impfpflicht ausgesprochen das robert
koch institut meldet einen neuen
tageshöchstwert innerhalb von 24 stunden
registrierte das lka 81 1417 neue fälle
das sind 17 1077 mehr als vor einer
woche
316 menschen starben binnen eines tages
die sieben tage incident steigt auf 4
127,7 mit den steigenden zahlen wächst
auch der bedarf an pcr tests labore
stoßen an ihre grenzen
ok berichtet
berlin die inzidenz kratzt an der
tausendermarke lange schlangen vor den
testzentren geduld ist gefragt immer
mehr pcr tests erreichen die labore der
hauptstadt die kapazitätsgrenze wird
hier bereits erreicht
und wir selber sind im moment bei einem
peak angelangt seit beginn der pandemie
und reisen an manchen tagen die 100
prozent nicht alle labore in deutschland
sind so ausgelastet es gibt noch
kapazitäten omikron bringt aber noch nie
registrierte dynamik plus 56 prozent
wuchs die auslastung vergangene woche
experten erwarten dass die vorhandenen
gesamtkapazität bald ausgeschöpft sein
könnte wenn jetzt diese frei testung aus
der quarantäne mittels pcr oder aus
isolation mittels pcr denn auch noch
greifen wird rechnet mit noch mal mehr
proben und dann weiß ich wirklich nicht
wie wir das alles abarbeiten sollten
ohne dass man über eine priorisierung da
regeln schafft ein entsprechendes
regelwerk sein arbeit heißt es im
gesundheitsministerium
wer bei engpässen bevorzugt getestet
werden soll scheint unstrittig zu sein
meines erachtens betrifft es vor allem
den gesundheitsbereich wo es um die
diagnostik von schwerer erkrankungen
geht aber auch das personal kritischer
infrastruktur was wir frei testen müssen
nach isolationen quandt jene um es
wieder zum einsatz zu bringen
priorisiert wird auch links sind vielen
gesundheitsämtern beispiel berlin die
masse der fälle ist schlicht zu groß um
sie noch alle einzeln nachzuverfolgen es
ist so dass uns die meldung zu einem
zeitpunkt erreichen wo eine kontakt
nachverfolgung überhaupt keinen sinn
mehr gibt weil einfach so viel zeit
vergangen ist dass die menschen wenn sie
sich nicht an die ohnehin geltenden
allgemeinverfügung gehalten haben so
viele kontakte gehabt haben dass jedes
eingreifen des gesundheitsamtes
nachträglich vollkommen sinnlos ist
aller kraft gilt nur dem schutz von
pflegeeinrichtungen und krankenhäusern
immerhin von dort gibt es ermutigende
nachrichten die zahl der kogit
einweisungen geht etwas zurück
darauf haben viele eltern von 12 bis 17
jährigen gewartet die stiko empfiehlt
nun auch für jugendliche booster
impfungen mindestens drei monate nach
der vorangegangenen impfung das risiko
schwerer nebenwirkungen werde als sehr
gering eingeschätzt zum im tempo da
wurden gestern 780.000 dosen verabreicht
der großteil auffrischungsimpfungen und
52000 wurden er gebt immer wieder jedoch
werden impfausweise gefälscht so hat die
polizei heute in mehreren bundesländern
wohnungen durchsucht bei mehr als 100
menschen die sich bei einem bayerischen
hausarzt falsche bescheinigungen besorgt
haben sollen petra neubauer mit den
einzelheiten die praxis des hausarztes
im schwäbischen wemding ist seit monaten
geschlossen
doch das beben das von hier aus geht ist
heute an vielen orten spürbar
einsatzbesprechung der polizei bevor
eine groß angelegte razzia startet ziel
war es gefälschte impfausweise bzw zu
unrecht erworbene impfausweise
sicherzustellen schwerpunkt der etwa
sechsstündigen aktion ist bayern und
baden württemberg vereinzelt wird aber
auch in nordrhein westfalen und hessen
durchsucht es geht um jene die den arzt
vorsätzlich aufgesucht haben um sich von
ihm ein zertifikat ausstellen zu lassen
ohne geimpft zu sein bei der razzia wird
einigen blut abgenommen um ihren
tatsächlichen impfstatus zu überprüfen
im fokus stehen rund 100 verdächtige
ich hoffe mir dass die menschen sehen
dass das kein kavaliersdelikt ist dass
es auch eine abschreckende wirkung hat
und dass man letztendlich das leben von
anderen riskiert wenn man mit
fälschungen in diesem bereich hantiert
die polizei stellt 70 mobiltelefone und
80 impfpässe sicher die falschen
zertifikate könnten nun für viele ein
juristisches nachspiel haben wir einen
gefälschten impfausweis vorliegt
beispielsweise um ins restaurant zu
kommen der macht sich ganz klar strafbar
das hat der gesetzgeber erst kürzlich
eindeutig geregelt tätern droht eine
geldstrafe oder sogar gefängnisstrafe
von bis zu einem jahr der hausarzt aus
wemding soll auch einigen patienten
spritzen ohne impfstoff verpasst haben
die ermittlungen dauern an immerhin gilt
für ihn bereits seit herbst ein
berufsverbot
für die beschäftigten der mv werften
geht es um nichts weniger als um ihre
jobs am montag war insolvenz angemeldet
worden heute ein kleiner lichtblick die
löhne für dezember sollen jetzt
ausgezahlt werden aber noch ist nicht
klar wie es an den standorten in wismar
rostock und stralsund weiter gehen wird
susanne seidel berichtet alle hoffnungen
ruhen nun auf ihm christoph morgen der
vorläufige insolvenzverwalter der mv
werften am morgen informierte er die
belegschaft in wismar über seine
strategien erste gute nachricht
insolvenzgeld kommt aus einlagen bei der
arbeitsagentur die löhne bis
einschließlich februar sind gesichert
also das haben sie auch versprochen
ganz gut
zusammen halten heißt es jetzt
zusammenhalten bei der insolvenz stehen
knapp 2.000 jobs drei werften und ein
schiff auf dem spiel die global dream
soll einmal 1,5 milliarden euro kosten
sie wurde für den asiatischen genthin
konzern gebaut dem auch die werften
gehören oberstes ziel jetzt die
fertigstellung des schiffes um es dann
zu verkaufen wir brauchen einen abnehmer
für das schiff der abnehm agentin ist
selbst so wie man es aus der presse
jedenfalls lesen kann selbst auch
angeschlagen sollte geld in den schiffs
greifen nicht zahlen können beginnt die
suche nach einem neuen käufer das land
bürgt schon für gut 300 millionen euro
und braucht dringend eine lösung
außerdem wollen wir gemeinsam mit der
bundesregierung dazu habe ich mit allen
wichtigen minister in der
bundesregierung gesprochen in einer
gemeinsamen arbeitsgruppe auch darüber
beraten wie die zukunft hier in
mecklenburg vorpommern für die standorte
aussieht klare perspektiven für die drei
standorte wismar rostock und stralsund
gibt es bisher noch nicht erste
überlegungen gehen richtung maritime
gewerbeparks oder die offshore-branche
der ukraine konflikte und das verhältnis
zu russland stehen beim treffen der eu
außen und verteidigungsministerium
minister im französischen brest ganz
oben auf der tagesordnung
außenministerin bernburg war ein dialog
mit russland von europäischen union
erwarte sie ein signal der
geschlossenheit
auf künftige konflikte wer sich die eu
besser vorbereiten dazu zählt der aufbau
einer schnellen eingreiftruppe die die
eu künftig militärisch unabhängiger
machen soll
vor genau zehn jahren ging nach rom mehr
als 4200 passagiere und crewmitglieder
an bord des kreuzfahrtriesen costa
concordia um das mittelmeer zu erkunden
beim abendessen wollte der kapitän den
gästen eine spektakuläre vorbeifahrt an
der insel leo bieten aber der
stahlkoloss rammte ein felsen und
kenterte während bei der rettungsaktion
32 menschen starben suchte der kapitän
das weite er sitzt seine haft heute am
jahrestag wurde der opfer gedacht
die überfahrt auf die insel guilio fällt
ihnen nicht leicht zehn jahre nach der
katastrophe der costa concordia kehren
esterházy und ihre tochter an den ort
zurück an dem sie als passagiere vor dem
ertrinken gerettet wurden
es ist sehr emotional und wir sind sehr
aufgewühlt vor allem wollen wir dort
sein um der menschen zu gedenken die
nicht mehr unter uns weilen
am abend des 13 januar 2012 starten sie
mit über 3000 passagieren zur kreuzfahrt
ins westliche mittelmeer nach einem
waghalsigen manöver vor video mit der
ruhm von einem felsen aufgerissen nach
chaotischen zuständen an bord kommt für
32 menschen jede hilfe zu spät
der kapitän francesco totti no verlässt
das schiff zu früh verurteilt zu 16
jahren haft sitzt er am zehnten
jahrestag im gefängnis in rom den sketch
kino machen steht seither im
italienischen sprachgebrauch dafür ein
feigling zu sein das wrack der costa
concordia wird zur metapher eines
finanziell wirtschaftlich und moralisch
gestrandeten landes was folgt es die
größte bergungsaktionen der geschichte
der italienischen seefahrt und auch die
große hilfsbereitschaft für die 4000
geretteten damals wirft ein gutes licht
es gibt nicht nur die tragödie sondern
auch die große geste der solidarität auf
unserer insel
ist der aussie und ihre tochter gedenken
der 32 opfer und danken für ihr zweites
leben das vor zehn jahren auf die leo
begann die tragödie der costa concordia
wird für immer ein teil der insel
bleiben
heute abend diese meldung aus
großbritannien die queen hat ihrem sohn
prinz andrew alle militärischen ins
gerade und royalen schirmherrschaften
entzogen gegen ihn gibt es schwere
vorwürfe im skandal um sexualisierte
gewalt um jeffrey epstein in den usa
ende werde sich im prozess als privater
bürger verteidigen so der buckingham
palast in london
der titel europäische kulturhauptstadt
ist etwas besonderes dieses jahr wird
damit unter anderem novi sad
ausgezeichnet eigentlich sollte die
zweitgrößte stadt serbiens im
vergangenen jahr kulturhauptstadt sein
aber wegen der pandemie wurde es
verschoben heute nun die feierliche
eröffnung unter dem motto für neue
brücken wolf christian ulrich berechnet
novi sad hat vielen herrschern gedient
und viele kriege erlebt die
jugoslawienkriege sind dabei nicht mal
25 jahre her wenn der bildhauer nicola
matura die flex ansetzt wird aus altem
kriegsgerät allerdings ein
musikinstrument seine art der
musikalischen vergangenheitsbewältigung
ich möchte diese kriegs objekte so
umgestalten dass sie ihren klang
verändern und wie sie im frieden für
etwas neues verwenden können
so klingt ein cello das mal ein
raketenwerfer war brücken bauen wo
fallende kämpften ist das motto der
kulturhauptstadt die erwartungen sind
groß denn der kulturelle austausch soll
auch dabei helfen trotz erheblicher
politischer vorbehalte serbiens ego
perspektive zu unterstützen
das ist sicher eine botschaft von europa
uns in serbien dass wir mithalten können
und dass man uns als teil der
gemeinschaft der europäischen nationen
die auseinandersetzung mit dem multi
kulturellen erbe von novi sad und ihre
starke tradition der wissenschaften
sollen in rund 1500 veranstaltungen
thematisiert werden die mitte die die
stadt dafür mobilisiert sind beachtlich
in diesen minuten wird das
kulturhauptstadt jahr feierlich eröffnet
was den veranstaltern allerdings sorgen
macht ausgerechnet jetzt breitet sich
omikron rasant in serbien aus schon
heute mussten erste veranstaltungen
abgesagt werden
umso größer die hoffnungen auf
sorgenfreie kultur momente mit vielen
gästen im sommer
und jetzt zur handball
europameisterschaften arbeit beginnt ja
heute abend hier eine zwei länder em in
ungarn und der slowakei die deutsche
mannschaft hat morgen erste spiel in
bratislava gegen belarus sorgen bereiten
dem dhb team die krone situation und
mängel im hygiene konzept des
veranstalters
belarus vor der brust die
allgegenwärtige bedrohung corona stets
im blick es ist der schwierige spagat
von alfred gislason und seinem team vor
dem turnier staat also wir haben ja das
würde ich jetzt ein bisschen schwarzer
humor bei aber auch spaß halber gesagt
wir müssen nur gesund bleiben da kommen
wir schon relativ weit beim dritten
vorrundengegner polen der im selben
hotel wie der dhb wohnen sind fünf
spieler positiv getestet worden während
in der slowakei die hallen maximal nur
zu einem viertel gefüllt sein dürfen
gibt es in ungarn keinerlei
beschränkungen auch in den team
unterkünften ist vorsicht ein fremdwort
wir waren alle fassungslos und sogar
schockiert als wir nicht maskierte gäste
sahen auch dass wir am selben ort wie
andere gäste essen mussten so der
französische ausnahmespieler karabatic
weitaus angenehmer wenngleich auch nicht
sorgenfrei die lage im deutschen
quartier
benedikt doll hat beim biathlon weltcup
in ruhpolding als zweiter im sprint sein
bisher bestes ergebnis im olympia-winter
geschafft nach fehlerfreiem schießen
fehlten dem 31 jährigen ex weltmeister
am ende nur 7,2 sekunden zum dritten
sieg in seiner karriere gewinner der
franzose konzerte jona je die
norwegischen spitzen athleten waren
nicht am start
gute deutsche ergebnis so auch beim ski
weltcup in wengen wo mit baumann
verpasst beim super-g haarscharf das
podium und wird vierter joseph ferstl
sechster
und auch vier tage vor dem start der
australian open ist die teilnahme von
novak djokovic ungewiss der serbische
tennis star trainierte heute in
melbourne und bekam auch schon seinen
turnier auftaktgegner zugelost aber die
australischen behörden könnten ihm wegen
falscher angaben in seinen ein
reiseunterlagen das wiso wieder
entziehen der anlagen soll angeblich
endlich entschieden werden ob djokovic
bleiben darf oder ausweisen mussten wir
werden sehen
und jetzt wollen wir noch herzliche
geburtstagsgrüße senden der kinderkanal
von ard und zdf wird 25 seit der kicker
schalter zum sendestart umgelegt wurde
gibt es für alle altersklassen einiges
zu sehen vom sandmännchen für die ganz
kleinen
über reichlich action bis zu den
kolleginnen und kollegen die sich bei
logo hier im studio etwas mehr austoben
dürfen als wir bei den erwachsenen
nachrichten happy birthday also an und
das ist nur ein kleiner schritt für ein
brot
zum wetter da gibt es wenig neues auch
morgen dominieren wolken und nebel wo
sich wann die sonne zeigt sagt uns
gleich katja horneffer christian sievers
begrüßt sie um 21 45 zum heute journal
[Musik]
in einigen regionen süddeutschlands
blieb ist heute den ganzen tag über
trieb auch im rhein-main-gebiet diese
nebeldecke über nordrhein westfalen zog
dagegen etwas weiter nach norden
gleichzeitig zogen auch hohe wolken hier
über den osten deutschlands und mit
denen haben wir jetzt auch in der nacht
zu tun über ganz norddeutschland ist die
wolkendecke dicht im süden bildet sich
nebel dann wird auch kalt am alpenrand
sinken die temperaturen bis minus zehn
grad unter den dichteren wolken im
norden bleibt es bei 6 bis 4 grad milder
und morgen erwarten uns dann meist sex
ist 9 grad und nur wenn sich der nebel c
hält dann liegen die temperatur nur
wenige grad über null und auch morgen
wird es wieder hin und wieder sehr trüb
bleiben an den alpen und auch auf
einigen berggipfeln süddeutschland sehen
sie die sonne dagegen strahlend im
norden sind die wolken dichter bringen
etwas nieselregen mit werden aber
wahrscheinlich spätestens am nachmittag
bei einem starken zum teil sogar
stürmischem nordwestwind es direkt an
der küste auch wieder auseinander reißen
am samstag wird sich noch wenig ändern
am sonntag kommen dann von norden regen
wolken heran und am montag könnte es für
etwas schnee reichen zumindest mal in
den östlichen mittelgebirgen ist sehr
windig guten abend